multi-level marketing once seen as the
new way
to make a part-time or full-time income
from home
now it's almost universally ridiculed
and mocked by anyone because
guys we've done the experiment the
numbers are in it's a failing business
model that doesn't work except
if you're at the tippity-tippy top if
you can get enough suckers
underneath you to lose money you can
then make money that is true
that is an honest thing they say take a
load off grab some popcorn and enjoy
the marketing versus the reality get
ready for some
um contradictions some hypocrisy some
lies
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the 10
million dollar studio i'm your host
coffee zilla and today
you know what we're taking a look at uh
some of the great mlms
right let's first watch some of the
marketing right bring down
the computer monitor of course our first
the first thing we're gonna be looking
at is
amway you guys know them they're sort of
um the original
schemers the original get rich quick
scheme
and uh let's take a look at what they
say about themselves
how can i get started do you really want
to know let me show you
dude han zimmer get in on this
there they are the schemers
[Music]
so they're showing themselves with
famous people okay we get it
relax you sell like potions and lotions
to women
at home you're not exactly flying things
to the moon with spacex
you don't need to do this it's just a
bunch of irrelevant numbers
what do we need to know is like can you
make a living with emily we give people
opportunities to have a
business of their own they will do
things
imagined possible before
[Music]
okay that's way too much out of amway's
mouth is so
that right before that that's doug devos
the now
president of amway and he's saying look
we're empowering people with businesses
so number one red flag no you're not you
are a
employee well you're in a consultant
you're a
independent contractor for amway but
you're not a business owner
let's be completely clear about that but
i think you get the idea from the dc
comics trailer here you're gonna make a
lot of money with amway it's an exciting
place to work
with a lot of money 40 billion dollars
in bonuses and incentives they say
so how much do you really make from
amway well it turns out
if you're in the bottom fifty percent
you make about four hundred dollars
if you're in the top ten percent the
median income is three thousand dollars
average eleven thousand that's worse
than working at
mcdonald's which means only one thing
mcdonald's is
the greatest income opportunity of our
era
no seriously if you work a minimum wage
job at mcdonald's you're making more
than 90 of amway employees or
independent business owners whatever
they call that's such a lie by the way
top 1
okay ladies and gentlemen 43 000 median
income
guys you're the valedictorian and you're
making like a regular wage
from like a regular job this does not
justify
wow maybe the way we start recruiting
for walmart
mcdonald's is by start playing like the
employee thing but instead
briana gets a demonstration from the
master burger builder
now next up on the chopping block oh
buddy
we've been needing to do this one for a
while patrick bett david ladies and
gentlemen owner
and founder of people helping people
and mlm focused on life insurance you
may know him though from his youtube
channel
valuetainment now i have no problem with
valuetainment i like it i'll watch
patrick all day on valuetainment to be
quite honest with you but
the mlm pack what are you doing with the
mlm because
it bills itself as like solving all the
problems guys
it says you know student debt crisis
what's gonna save you let's watch their
advertising
will the rising trade tensions between
the us and the china just
keep pushing these markets lower
underemployment among recent college
grads
saving for a retirement put some fear
it's not easy to ignore
the financial problems we have today in
retirement
not a chance everyone talks about it
you get very few bring financial
solutions to solving
oh boy here we go big big promises until
now
the champ is here the tap
is here the champ is here
one company dares to dream bigger and do
the impossible
when company pushes the limits of the
status quo
wow we got it all guys we got people
smoking cigars fat cats dude this is a
lot like the amway thing it's like a
younger amway
it's nice it's uh it's uh fresh it's
exciting
so what is the reality of php according
to
the disclosure they have to file let's
check it out because
they say they have the top compensation
plan
with the top compensation package in the
marketplace for entrepreneurial
agency builders php is ushering a new
era
of multicultural and diverse agents
wow so you heard them world class this
is the best we're going to get today in
terms of compensation
plans so it better be good so uh a
little we got to go through a little bit
of this the first thing you have to
notice
this is a measure of the average of the
life licensed
agents in the periods of january through
december 31st
uh 2019. so i wanted to make sure to get
2019's income disclosure because i know
covid
shook things up i didn't want to uh yeah
get that in the mix
so this is that and it's for agents that
got their license because i know you
have to get like licensed with these
kinds of businesses so i wanted to make
sure we measured
the licensed agents and they said this
is licensed agents well let's check out
the numbers
800 000 of income that's pretty good
well how many people get that
0.13 okay so it drops pretty steeply off
from that
okay 300 000 not bad 0.14
now going on from that like you
basically have one percent of people
making a really good income it seems
like
because 0.75 make 148 000 that's a great
living you're gonna do very well with
that
well now we drop into the middle class
right one percent
of the people do that it's still great
still good compensation
here's where it really falls off down
here i don't know if you can see that
64 percent of paid agents these are
agents getting paid
made 200 the vast majority
of people who made money with php barely
paid
off their uh enrollment fee of 200
that year you didn't even hardly broke
even on an enrollment fee
over half now uh 20 of them made
2 000 in a single year terrible income
let's just be honest that's not in
that's like a side hustle at best
seven thousand same thing six percent of
people made that
meaning that about 90 of php's employees
also make
less than uh take a guess everyone got
their guests ready
mcdonald's employees yes ladies and
gentlemen the number one
compensation plan in mlm the thing
that's changing everything that's
changing a world full of debt mcdonald's
starting salary makes more than 90 of
those people
this isn't to dump on those people by
the way this is the
this mlm as a rule it just doesn't work
guys i always tell you mlms are scams
built to enrich the very people
at the very top and basically no one
else and to make money you have to
recruit people underneath you
now the thing is these people will tell
you well of course
of course stephen you know people that
uh not many people succeed it's just
like owning
a business a business where most people
don't succeed except
there's a problem with that you don't
have to go out and base your success
on getting new suckers in the program
this is the problem with him a limb
emma lim's involved the majority of
their work is hey
you gotta go recruit so in order for you
to succeed this is what makes mlms
completely unique
you have to make other people go lose
you get that
because to succeed you have to recruit
and to recruit
you have to knowingly bring people into
a system where 90
of the people make less than a
mcdonald's salary where it's probably
slightly more than that right
yeah actually it is because actually
it's 95 percent of people because these
4.8 percent make only 15 000 a year i
think a minimum wage at mcdonald's
makes a little bit over that how do they
get away with this stuff man
it's mind blowing to me now we're gonna
look at another
uh mlm called vemma and again these are
their numbers not mine
damn this bra makes my breasts feel
amazing michelle you should get this bra
but in the bra
world if if she bought a bra
is this guy drunk this is like vemma
sales guy what's going on here
i ain't getting jack shinola that's
right no jack shinola guys
but you know what with v-ma vemma you're
getting jack shinola if i tell her to
buy that bra
i'm getting broken off some that's what
it's about
peer to peer nobody watches commercials
say that to like
the billion dollar advertising industry
you buffoon no one ever sits and looks
at billboards and goes
yo man i could see that movie no you
hear it from what
your friend this is the greatest lie
ever
forget about hey forget about the ad age
where everyone's like sitting glued to
their phone what are you gonna advertise
on someone's phone
no dude you're gonna go up to their door
and knock on it and go recruit them
or better yet you're gonna tell your
friends hey use promo code vemma at
checkout
like what do you think's gonna happen
your homeboy your hombre tell them
how they can make money the whole thing
is every time i drink this i'm making
money you just get two of your friends
to be customers they tell two of their
friends
i love how this is like the broke
version of multi-level marketing like
this is like
the poor guy's version of a pyramid
scheme it's like they're not even
not even try they're not even trying to
make this look legitimate it's like hey
man
it's just like you drink the stuff man
and then you make money now of course
when you go to their uh
disclosure statements you will find that
forty percent of the people make
nine hundred dollars anyway you go down
the list and you find that once again
the vast majority make less than
a walmart employee yes i'm changing it
up for mcdonald's now what i love about
this
these guys are always talking about how
they're different how nine to fives
suck and it's such poetic justice that
they actually
end up making the vast majority of them
way way
less than if they had just gone and been
a walmart greeter
now for our last commercial today guys
i hope you've enjoyed it by the way so
far let me know if you have in the
comments below we're checking out eye
markets live
stock guys austin gatsey you've seen
these guys
what are you doing right now watching
you cringing
clearing the path of wealth and a
lifestyle most dream of
probably not do you have enough honestly
in doubt to retirement
no enjoy life and take care of your
health
do you have enough to take care of your
family
nah looking for the bag honestly if i
can get a job with you guys
pay me well i'll shell why not enjoy
your life now
and make massive money enough to enjoy
later also
yes guys this
is a bit on the nose don't you think
don't you think this is a little too
much
no marketing team didn't think this was
not subtle enough
yes
you can be as successful as a wall
street trader without spending years to
acquire the knowledge
yes ladies and gentlemen the old don't
spend time to make money
get rich quick is that basically what
you're saying because you're saying
don't spend any time learning think so
let's check out their income disclaimer
guys
uh yeah you go ahead and you find out
67 of eye markets live people
are barely cracking a hundred dollars
which i think is less
less than the fee sixteen percent are
cracking under a grand
nine percent are cracking under two
grand have you noticed a similarity
between
all of these income disclosures first of
all they're all promising you
wild success everyone says they have the
greatest compensation plan in the world
the reality is a bunch of losers
a couple winners and the only reason and
this is important
they're gonna say well the couple of
winners they just had heart they're real
true workers
and everyone needs to be like no the
reason they're winning is because they
got enough people underneath them to
step on top of none of this works
without the down line that's the
important key
in order to do an mlm properly you
cannot have everyone succeeding
that's literally you can't do it it
wouldn't work
the way this works is 90
or more usually 95 98 have to fail
miserably in order for
the one percent the 2 percent to make it
and do be wildly successful and then
they tell you
hey greatest income opportunity of our
era no
i reject that anyways guys that's
basically it pump the stock you could
make as much as a wall street trader
with none of the education
um thanks for watching i'll see you guys
next time
i know what you need this ain't what it
seems nothing but a trick trying to sell
me on a dream but that was where you
lost me
wake up and smell the coffee